コンチョドクター
あああああ ca というわけでみなさん特に男性の処分ですねデートに行かれるとき
何されてますか
まあデートといえば見た目とか服装とかすごい大事だと思うんですけどももっと大事な
ことあると思うんですよ
そう
すまんそうです皆さんベイトの時って女性の里近づく時があると思うんですけどもその
瞬間にめちゃくちゃいい匂いがしたらどう思われると思いますか
love になっちゃうんですよそうです男性の将軍大事なのは匂いなんです
なぜ小姓衆とかあの匂い行きぜっていうの大事なんですけどももっと素敵な男性になる
ためには
いいよまとうことがとても大事だと思います
そんな時にこちら ax ですねはいこちらめちゃくちゃ避けるだけでいいのになるん
ですよ
届けかけてみましょうか
[音楽]
今自分が好きになりました
本体なので匂いだけでね1どからの見え方って変わると思うんですよ
そこで私考えてしまいましたこのサイズでも十分なんですけども
この ax をもっと大きくすればどうなるのかということで今回
中央巨大訳すをつくってみましたこちらです
[音楽]
はいというわけでこっち裸画像巨大や
でございます覧くださいこちらが普通のサイズそしてこちらが兄弟ややばいもうこの
距離でようやく同じくらいのサイズ感ですね
このさんやばいいでしょう
バッハこんなにを下がるんですよこれでこれらの見た目だけじゃなくてちゃんとあの
スプレーとして機能しております作るのがとっても大変でした
ご覧くださいどうぞ
car
me
ええええええ
a 敷かれパジェラーの今回は専門的すぎてあまり僕にできることがありませんでした
全然がーもうこれ本当にいろいろ見た目も完全にあっつの巨大版なんでもうこれを使え
ば誰でもすぐ
いいになれるそんな気がしておりますでは早速風車よく試していこうと思いますちらに
ドクタージンのまだやった
とかないのでどれぐらいの風車ようになっているのかわかりません
8このサイズ感じゃないぞではいきます
つい
わー
tan
ああ
あーあ自然の青い最大限のすごい
広範囲に広がるこの香りすばらしいですかも威力たまらんですよ
カメラビシャビシャんですけどもうカメラがべちゃべちゃになってしまいました
ですが今ので威力は証明されました
結婚ん
ポッ型 o 型5を2
はいというわけですね
カメラのセッティングが完了しましたあとはに気をいを気にしない
イケてない後輩をによ帰るだけこの
ちょうだいアークスが2人のとっきりで何を知らない程度家に入ってくるんで
この間小枝上がってきたらおっしゃっ
てくる感じになると思いますはい
新しいよ
あれー
オセロああ
は党是 a
4大越大丈夫はいね持ったんだぞ
汚れやばいはい
エロい子なにこれ
[拍手]
ブーバーし
ぞねっパン前かぁ
キュッ
世界ですねー
とニオイの悩みグッチジュエリー良い一いやいやいやう
イライラいやいや良いですよこれ
ブーバーいい自然にカーリーいい
ブーブーいやいやあああぬーっ
パンフレット前買われその他て麺がニオイ気にしてないから
ああ
を言われます前回のバックスゲートに続き
いいのになってもらいたいなと思ってなるほど準備しました
いやありがたいですねぇはいというわけで巨大アックスを使って後半より入院してみた
んですけども
やっ
ブーブー恵山ぜひ ax 使ってみて
だーう nope パティ上下
4編とに出演することになりましたぁーっ
何度ですね都内近郊で数百人で巨大なイベントをやろうと思っておりますので皆さん
是非
3月13日から5月13日までアークスを購入して応募してみてください
ドクタードレが待ってるよ詳細は動画概要欄のリンクから確認できますので是非皆さん
チェックしてみてください
皆さんも ax でをどこ
を見るこザーン
だだ最後す
[音楽]
me
バッハ